and oh hi and welcome to see you're
playing not kovitch and probably sorry
yep a summary with g6 experimenting with
the sly landed I think it works rather
well yeah it's a very late release for
this video and I didn't manage to do it
earlier channel glad that I get
something released here on them on this
wednesday and now i actually have played
a game earlier just a couple of minutes
ago which I which I lost terribly and
nobody probably is going to believe me
that but I absolutely accidentally press
the delete button instead of releasing
this i got totally killed in a king's
gambit was a pretty embarrassing game
but i did it did what is it yeah it
doesn't make sense to only yeah only
release your wins um but i absolutely
pressed the wrong button I mean I was
just about to get resigned and instead
of resigning i press the press the
delete button okay anyway let's see what
we can do against mr. Lott kovitch I
think this looks like a decent decent
position out of this opening let's open
up in the center and let's see what
happens
like many many central parts looks quite
nice ok I'm going to take its night's
mega fairly passive impression him so
how to do it even h5 make some sensor to
make g4 more difficult to play let's see
maybe we can undermine oh it's a good
move push an h4 he wants to play so I
should prevent that once you go to d4
here
yeah that's not good that's absolutely
not good what I'm doing here oh okay so
can I Wow remarkably bad well maybe he
overlooks 95 no one he doesn't you can
always hope it is also playing super
quickly which is also not good news okay
so you might take there maybe this one
controlling d4 Queen to d4 is a is a
huge issue he wants to maybe take and
play Queen h4 check
okay that's a very very bad position
Wow the edge is very bad you played well
I play badly the combination is not good
i'm pretty sure that position must have
been pretty good for black check anyway
check check check I mean a couple of
months ago I think black was fine would
be really strange if not with a big
Center and everything I mean I have some
weaknesses but still ok some
it's a big check big check here and i
have no good way to cover it twin 86 and
i really don't want to go there but
don't really see an alternative here at
the moment
okay so maybe a check the night you will
play be three anyway I guess what I have
okay i don't i don't have time but i can
know when to it down so now remarkably
bad position
Roxy 5 there's a chick cannot even go on
I have six years it's not even possible
great can only only hope that he makes
them who ran this blunder position is
completely lost time morning we can do
absolutely nothing here check okay if i
get d 5 and at least I can continue the
game this this is actually not so clear
unless you find some other some new
great movie
don't see a great discovery here ok i
will see is that so clear fire if i play
for the B porn I don't know that wasn't
the best way of handling things for him
they are winning now it's very
undeserved maybe a draw maybe it
there will be one I don't think I can
win that's very unfortunate don't see
you in-game draw no eyes open King be
three wins okay and now here he wants
the deal I know this because it's no
check so I'm actually winning in the day
at the end okay yeah when we undeserved
anyway he got he totally killed me I
would like to understand where my
position become became worse because he
a black is fine absolutely fine this is
rather weakness the nights are passive
so I must have done something really bad
what was what will my sins here maybe
age five already okay g4 wasn't a big
deal but I thought that's prevented the
engine wants to play be fired
immediately this kind of thing that a
father it looks better I probably oops i
probably lost too much time here and now
it wants me to play a loop c8 and not
night g sixteen or before be 492 and
Queen B 7 immediately try to win this
with equal play here and hereafter this
instant probably gets gets difficult
German here I'm in bad shape oh no I can
take you five I didn't look at this that
looks so scary my computer is some check
when i call sir
it knows no fear or wow that looks very
dangerous computer just gives equal
equal equal zero with I had looks very
dangerous for luck Cheyenne the way a
chat went out I got completely
completely busted just and kind of held
on and try to not lose a meal and then
here check then you go got into this and
now things have turned completely or
King d7 already wins and I saw that but
I didn't see this move and then winning
ok Jack taking is also ok so here an
hour yeah this is I think just a problem
and what the computer finds a draw with
rook a fade with this this is losing
Jeff up to be three which I did not see
him I did not see I mean I didn't have
much time but it's a bit of a shame
would have been cool too and to win dad
to win that game but I didn't have any
time to to figure it out ok well thanks
for watching